had a man involved in a deadly DUI crash
last November learned his fate in court
today Jonas nedia previously agreed to a
plea deal back in January and was
sentenced up to six years today now
court documents say that nedia smashed
into the victim Andrea Robles her car
hit a pole and it caught fire now Nettie
his attorney says he's trying to clean
up his act but the Robles family feels
differently
you know my sister's 16 years old and
I've lived over my mom so you know I
mean this has been the most
best-up thing that's ever happened in
our family like
um
I I don't think he's getting enough time
Jonas Nadia previously admitted to
drinking tequila and smoking pot before
that crash